le rap fait son apparition à la
télévision française dans les années 80
[Musique]
les isp audrey attendre le milieu des
jeunes 90 pour voir des rappeuses ispa
as tu m'entends dans talent avec leur
musique elle est déjà cette question
karine vous êtes chanteuse vous êtes
rappeuse il ya moins de km2 femmes que
d'hommes dans le mouvement ou autant si
ya pas de femme pas des masses y en a un
peu mais bon elles sont pas vraiment
reconnu quoi c'est dur de se faire
reconnaître parce que dans le milieu du
rap il ya surtout des mecs et les matchs
aux machos en 1999 l'émission sagacité
consacre une demi heure à l'apparition
des femmes sur la scène rap lady lay
citées par ta vision choquant et
les
médias
le vent commence à tourner les labels
commence à faire signer des rappeuses
selon les artistes tout serait question
de marketing des fois maintenant je
viens d'avoir sa fille qui rappe propre
lit mais bon je pense qu'il ya un petit
côté de marketing mais c'est pas grave
parce que les les filles comme moi quel
club de signer dans une maison disque
elles ont quand même leur personnalité
est savent où ils veulent aller à
l'époque diam's à 18 heures donc voilà
jean maintenant critique du rappeur ou
de radio soummam
même si les labels s'intéressait aux
rappeuse se faire une place et est
encore un combat de chaque instant
aujourd'hui les fnac et virgin
bah je sais pas ils ont pas trop axé
là-dessus les mains sur les tempes
patron
c'est pas grave on créa train jours mais
ce qui va tout bouleverser c'est en 2015
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas une pompe partie tchèque
victoire de la musique du meilleur album
rap en 2004 et le succès du morceau la
boulette disque de platine diam's va
devenir la référence faisant de l'ombre
à tous d autres talents même en 2017
alors qu'elle s'est retirée du monde de
la musique les journalistes qui font
encore référence alors il ya peu de
chanteuses dans le rap
avec la retraite anticipée de diam's il
n'y a pas vraiment de deux femmes
qu'occupe le gamescom
jargon alors c'est peut-être que le
public un peu plus de mal à accepter les
femmes mais je me vois plutôt bien
aujourd'hui l'univers du rap restent
encore majoritairement masculin mais la
jeune génération s'organise série
concerts festivals la scène dans à se
féminiser un peu plus
[Musique]